every time we we have a child which is
not like that many times but we we uh
how many children do you have three
which is like that's a lot I guess it is
a couple many times but but uh we we
pick names based on like we try to roast
the name as best we can so that we
anticipate all the things they'll be
called in school uh-huh good and Drake
just felt like I don't think there's ma
like it felt foolproof yeah snake pretty
good but I know
that sounds like a wrestler yeah
[Applause]
yeah just naming kids after your
favorite performers my daughter Beyonce
is gonna love this yeah I have to tell
you well she'll get along great with my
other son
um Steven Spielberg
it'll be a party yes all three of my
kids have like New York uh like cool
names Drake Drake George Grace oh and
Cole oh good name fantastic you're a
good dad oh thank you